that we looks like we can see the
england team getting on the bus there
and they'll be able to see those fans
won't they they'll be able to hear them
uh you can see a lot of flags being
waved i wonder if there's as much
singing down there unfortunately
from the helicopter we can't hear any
sound but we're seeing an england flag
being draped over
uh the beautifully clipped hedge there
so they're on the bus no not no big fuss
they didn't stop a bit of a wave there
is that possibly garrison
a bit of a wave for the fans as they're
coming out of the hotel
and then on to this bus and down to
wembley
i think it's usually two buses as well
just because we're covered regularly
well that was certainly the case in
italy
but because we were right beside them as
they came out we i mean as you can see
from the fans there
beyond when the players have been in
stadiums it doesn't feel like they've
been this close to the atmosphere
and even i'd say like uh i'm at wembley
now we're having
you know what to live in south london
and haven't made my way
to the stadium today it is just amazing
how the atmosphere has taken over and
really
ratcheted up even from the germany game
which maybe felt the first
event really on a different level well
like when you walk around london and i'm
sure it's just a
certain case the players think you're
eventually going to hear kind of
whistling or singing a sweet caroline
or three lions and i mean as you can see
from the images there that's
i'm sure at another level entirely
around the team
and and it's important isn't it i mean
that's what gary southgate has said he's
tried to do he's tried to shield the
fans from
from the madness because he wants them
just to take each game at a time
and be you know slow and steady and
meticulous in their preparation and
just focus on the game rather than
focusing on the hysteria
do you think that's the secret that's
how he's managed to get the team
so far already there's certainly an
element to that yeah and even
i suppose what gives an insight in
itself is that
as we saw the joyous scenes uh after
beating and
beating denmark in the semi-final and
when as all the players are singing
sweet caroline
senke told us that he wasn't actually
thinking of
the euphoria or the um
or the meaning of being a finalist he
was actually still mulling over
what happened in the game and what
needed to be fixed